oh my opponent typed in Fisher random I
guess they wanted to Fisher and I'm
after all okay cool now what do we do
with this arrangement how refreshing it
is to actually start off with something
different that makes you think right
from the beginning here I'd like to have
this sepan out before I develop my night
and the other reason for that well upon
on c5 is going to support night moves to
maybe one of these two squares and it's
going to let my bishop come out I'll
doll right now I can't do it I think I
might want to mimic White's move yeah I
think that's a good start Knight to f6
is probably good and what else hmm
interesting um there's pressure on this
pond right here if I play here i'm
stopping that well let's defend it even
though my bishop looks like an idiot
right now I don't want to play night
here to defend the pond because I want
this guy to be able to do something so
let's get my night out and actually my
dark square Bishop I don't know i'm i
don't know what i want to do with him if
i push here that really weakens this
square I really don't want to do that
let me play here and what next pond push
and then Bishop hear something Bishop to
f7 I think there's a couple quick moves
i could be making soon Bishop f7 seems
to be one of them Queen here seems to be
another and let me take that I don't
think having my structure compromises a
good idea would they get would they give
up the dark square Bishop just to double
my pawns probably not a good idea my
light square Bishop needs to do
something here interesting okay I really
enjoy these 960 games um how about
cleanup and then I'm ready to Castle
these Kings side where is this not gonna
go okay there there it goes and one or
two squares with this pun I want to play
my bishop to this square I'm going to go
two squares maybe look for a 483
right here or anything better than that
I don't think so Bishop e7 can't Castle
queenside as soon as I move this rook
hmm what you do here Bishop takes bishop
rook takes Bishop the rook is
unprotected there might be queen pivots
hitting my broken something else really
wouldn't be hitting anything other than
my rook okay well I don't have any other
reply ok our queen there and now what do
I do if I react maybe there's a night
move here I think I just commonly come
back I don't know if I want a week in my
light squares with the pawn push like
that I think I'm going to follow suit
King side castle and now I'm going to do
this to clamp down in this structure so
there's also maybe night move here and
well I'm going to actually hang on to my
light square Bishop even though it looks
a bit stupid being hemmed in behind
these ponds I do have possibilities for
this move but not so fast if I play here
there's Queen takes pawn in between move
I'm actually going to run with this move
now and if Queen here at this point now
I'm going to make this move earlier I
said I wouldn't do that but I'm gonna do
it then ok this night needs to go got to
get out of there night and now I think
this could turn out to be an annoying a
pin Bishop here or maybe here where's
the night gonna go oh this could be a
problem pins pins pins oh oh this rook
is still hanging
pond push is not working because I take
here Bishop here still not working
because I take here this might be the
best but I think I win material after
that d 3 takes if Queen moves I just
tucked my book back he's been going back
and forth here many times but okay so
now I think I take here first and there
is no pond recapture because the night
and okay now there's that and I just
react to it or play see 5 no I don't
like c5 let's just play here there still
is no politics take here and then maybe
there's something like a night upon push
a night here in a queen check getting on
this diagonal I'm up material no matter
what I'm up upon but this could turn out
to be a target these rooks coming to
this half open file and now there is
still this little pin going on there's
two pieces on this diagonal hmm
I really don't want to take
um
man if I take
interesting very very interesting oh man
okay well I'm going to play this rook
here I think there's some variations
where I want my rook on a to watch over
the a4 pawn if takes I have push and
there's there's the Queens that could
come off but at the end of it there's a
rook that I'm still observing so this is
if there's a rook to move to this square
I think it would be the rook for white
very tight real is real tight right now
I might have thoughts actually of
playing my queen back here to still
prevent pond takes so I could play this
ok and now that move is played okay I
think we go with this might be a pawn
push and I think I back up if that
happens
I'm going to go with this right now and
then pivot my knight in the center Queen
here there might be a pawn push I
support it with this might be a pawn
push here let's get out get out of this
the nights in a pin maybe this is better
just to make sure I secure my Knights
position pond here I do this oh I before
work i missed a fork again night dad for
this it's a whole family ah i would have
hit the whole family right there
positional again positional mentality my
opponent is saying whoops they're less
than 40 ah alright alright what can you
do what can you do you can still win
though um so it's still a good position
but of course go for the the quick kills
right there that was a quick killer now
I really don't want to deal with the
night landing on that for let's come
back here and then just play my rook
here okay and now I want to get rid of
that night as soon as it thinks about
stepping here right now don't you dare
maybe I can still get a fork I'm
watching out for him now okay let's come
here no time and what else okay now we
have some tactic check kill the Queen I
get something now this time right with
this check this fork um yes I'm going to
take the rook first actually I think
this is the cleaner approach and then
take one of these two
my opponents not moving oh they thrown
the whole farm at me the whole farm
stalemate this guy could move okay good
game that got pretty intense right there
a nice middle game struggle let's go
back here let's go back so what's the
scoop here um I already expressed my
ideas behind this I want my night to
come here behind the pond my bishop
could see um interesting decision to go
with that pun right away okay I have to
do something the bishops out I wonder if
an idea is like a quick d3e for putting
more pressure on this throwing another
pond in the center establishing it on e
four so where is there a big mistake I
think I'm it's still pretty equal right
here maybe this maybe this right here
all right I didn't play a four but right
now a 3 i think is not the right idea
maybe maybe instead of a 3 consider a
four because of what because of this
pond being able to clamp down on this
pond and he could be a potential target
later on with the rook up and over or
maybe a night getting here something
he's a mobile isn't is a my point a 3 a
4 i think that's a good positional grip
right here on that structure so maybe a
slight suggestion is uh a 4 and i just
don't know i'm liking my position I
don't have any weaknesses with regard to
my structure you really don't either I
think it's a bit awkward to have this
night stuck in front of the
on so I wonder if there's a way you can
work that one out like this right here
maybe the Queen move is not a good idea
in fact maybe this idea once again d3
and d4 d3 just to even watch out for my
night move here but as a follow-up that
II for advanced and if the night is
kicked away the night could come back to
a comfortable square on f3 that would be
a nice spot for the night to go to think
once once this happened right here
things start to become very
uncoordinated the night being on the
edge not being able to play here because
of takes and the loss of material so I
think maybe at this point even still
running with these a3 and a4 moves don't
play the Queen f3 move maybe it's just
played e3 and e4 the Knights hit you go
back to f3 and you stay a bit more
coordinated stay out of the way of your
Center ponds it's got to be real
uncomfortable I pinned I'm up I'm up
upon and I missed a fork mr. Ford King
in the corner deadly okay it happens
let's